We did the ads. What? Oh yeah, let's do this elder dude.
This was really cool. It touched me. We'll talk about good times and bad times.
This is a good segue into this. We're bringing it. We're putting an elder here.
Um, here, I got an email through my,
uh, um,
producer on the website. It's a log email.
I'm going to try to shorten it up for you guys. But, uh, this really,
this really touched me, dude. Uh, Hey Chris,
so I have a different request for you at the title is subject is my brother.
Hey Chris.
So I have a different request for you and the congratulations podcast to get
right to it.
I'm coming to you to humbly request that my brother be given the honor of
becoming an elder. Now, before I even go on here, let me stop right here.
So many people are like, am I an elder yet? Do I get to be an elder?
That's that takes you a few steps back from becoming an elder. Okay.
If you're asking to become an elder, that's like, you want it too bad.
It's like the karate guy. That's like, oh,
what do I have to do to become a black belt? You're in the wrong state of mind,
young grasshopper.
If you have with your eyes on the prize,
then you're not using one of your eyes for the journey. Now,
am I a I'm practically Confucius how I said that.
And that makes me just like him because I came up with a cool quote that I just
said, but dude,
actually think I heard that. So I'm not even that smart, but uh,
this guy is humbly asking for his brother to become
an elder,
which he's putting his self himself aside and trying to have
his brother become an elder elder. So when I listened to that,
when I read that I go in my head, I go, I'm listening.
Right?
Cause at first, Hey Chris, do I have a different request? I go,
I've heard it all. This is me. Hey Chris, do I have a different request for you?
I've heard it all.
That's me to.
Get right to you. I'm coming to you to humbly request. Yeah, sure, bro.
Here comes a joke. That's.
Me that my brother be given the honor of becoming an elder and then that's me
going? I'm listening. I'm like that. We pay meme.
Oh.
If I could explain why I believe that you will understand that my intentions are
pure and true. I'm listening. He's talking like he's in a cult. I like that.
As you have a similar relationship with your brother that is based on your
complete admiration for each other.
I love my brother.
I love my brother as much as Gerard, but loves Morgan free or free.
And the Angeles fallen series.
Um, my brother, Justin DEI is an air force, special tactics, airman listening.
Because why? Because why?
Because he's protecting me literally.
With the 23rd STS. Do I know what it means? No, because I'm,
I'm really dumb, but maybe some of you out there do,
he was deployed to an under dust undisclosed valley in Northeastern Afghanistan
in April of 2018 where he was attached to a green beret unit. Okay.
So he's a tough guy. Anytime I hear Greenbrae I think, okay.
If I ever got in a fight with that guy, he would, he would murder me.
They were tasked to clear the valley of enemy combatants from the valley and
into Pakistan approximately a week before he was going to be sent back home.
Justin stepped on an IED, which caused him to lose some fingers,
his leg above the knee. But also he had lost so much blood.
They had flat-lined for 90 seconds, which is,
I mean, what do you even say about that? He survived.
Thank God. But recovery was a horribly difficult process for him physically,
but most importantly,
mentally P T S D is a disgusting thing to see in someone you
love, especially one that I spent my entire childhood with loving and admiring.
I can't imagine, man. Uh,
this is my thank you to you and the entire congratulations.
Congratulations podcasts.
Then he says some stuff about me that I'll skip because that just seems like I'm
humble. Bragging. Uh, oh,
this is cool. He introduced you to his spec ops team.
And with that you have changed their vocabulary completely.
I'm humbled here. Thank you. Uh, oh,
he's trying to figure out a design for a congratulations tattoo. Uh,
please know, I know, uh, yeah, that's too much nice stuff for me. Um,
that's great, man. This is so you know, it's bittersweet. Uh,
I read it all very, uh, you guy says, look, I love this. He says,
um,
but mostly I can't think of a better Christmas gift for him than you granting
him an elder. Uh, I understand if not,
because I know how you have chosen elders in the past and they were all
deserving. Thank you for reading all of this. I know it's long as.
What a good guy, man, what a good guy,
what a good way to come at someone to there's no rules,
but this guy is a sweetheart.
And because of this beautiful letter and because of how selfless you are,
uh, I'm going to make your, your brother,
your hero, your hero brother, uh, an elder.
And um, I'm going to send you one too, dude, because he didn't ask for it. Uh,
so you guys are both elders and you can share that together and thank you for
listening.
Thank you for your service to Justin Day
and Braden day. Thank you for writing me this message. Uh,
and shout out to you and your team out there to, uh,
your spec ops team. That's just the sweetest man.
And sorry, you lost your leg a little.
Bit of your, or a lot of your leg and your fingers. Uh,
but just remember that
inside the basement in your laundry room,
in your secret department, in your laundry room,
into that candle lit seance that you know,
life reps anyway, uh, I, I love what you do for this country and that's amazing.
And Brayden, it sounds like you're a great family, man. You, you, you guys,
both of you guys, uh, yeah, that's, that's so cool.
So we'll be sending you your, your, your pins and your, or certificates. Uh,
Juan fire will be doing it. And thank you. Thank you so much.